13 years old you find a way to basically
escape to China right and you and your
mother go yeah okay you escape to China
how by crossing a frozen River and it
was it was so cold that the guards are
down like what is this what is this
situation how do people stop the illegal
immigration so they're like every 10
meters guards are the machine guns and
now after Kim Jong-un came he buried the
land of mines
and then put the electrified wire fences
and then facial recognition cameras from
China from the border so now it's big
escaping from Northgate became
impossible but you were before this
right I was right before that it was
still though like with the machine guns
and cars every 10 meters and they just
didn't see you because it was dark no
the people who the lady was helping me
she was a broker so she uh bribed the
guard that's why I didn't get shot okay
so she bribes the guards and then you
and your mother get across and then
immediately after getting across your
mother is sold I I you told this story
on Rogan yes
yeah now this is I need to ask something
you were telling the story and you said
in the story I need to know if you were
just using this as like uh vernacular
like we use it or this is true you said
that your mother was sold to mentally
[__] Farmers as a sex slave no no
yeah okay your mother was sold to
mentally [__] Farmers right now were
you saying that in terms of like like we
say oh they're mentally [__] like
people that are stupid or they were
actually they were they were mentally
ill people like that yeah actually tend
to function they cannot put their pants
on like you know they like limp like
actual physically sick and in their head
or so sick people and and they worked as
Farmers or they owned a farm or
something like that so they uh the one
my mom was sold several times so one
time she was sort of this family and the
of course the sun couldn't function he
was very disabled but uh parents and
they had a farm they it was like I think
private China privatized after the
shopping came right so they had their
own Farm holy [__] the family worked so
she's immediately sold there you also
sold
so immediately she was raped and
and the pros together
earning our price and then they realized
my mom was older so they sold for like
65 dollars for her and then I was a
child version of 13 and version so they
decided to serve me over 200 also sold
me separately to a different broker oh
my God and this is all part of the the
person that was transporting you she
knew when she was transporting you that
this would immediately happen on the
other side yeah so this is the cost of
getting out but the craziest thing is
that I'm not hating her is because she
sold her children the same way oh my if
I was not get sold into China you would
not see me because I've been dead 100
2007 yeah wow see me today oh my God the
only way you could survive is being sold
as a sex slave yeah wow and she got
executed for that after a few years
later somebody told her or the authority
caught her and then they executed
and when they execute her they also
arrest eight generations of her family
there is an elevation is up to a
generation between three and eight yeah
oh my God now I know that your father
was arrested earlier and when he was
arrested did other people also get
arrested with him so there is a two
types of crime in North Korea called
political crime and economic crime the
political crime is where what you do you
make fun of the president yeah that
cares eight Generations eight
Generations it's like literally one guy
at the top officially escaped more than
30 000 people got so you say that sent
to prison camp they did not even know
they were related to that guy because
they're so far out from in-laws of the
in-laws and in-laws right one guy yeah
and it was for being critical of the
president or criticizing escape to South
Korea and then criticize the regime so
he criticized the regime over there and
then they just scooped up his entire
family 35 000 people that were related
to him and that's how they sent the
message now those people they go to you
said there are three different types of
Prisons there yeah there's the
Concentration Camp uh labor camp labor
camp and then one uh re-education camp
the re-education camp the education Camp
is a bit less than three years sentence
she's in Camp is where my father sent
over 10-year sentence but like a prison
Campus of Lifetime sentence but when you
go to political prison camp you don't
last more than three months it's like uh
not Germany means you know gas chamber
they worked you to death they helped
them ask you to clean the degrees of
nuclear weapon those testing sites
that's why they didn't get all the
cancer you get of course oh they need
all these people to keep testing nuclear
weapons and then cleaning those
deliveries afterwards oh my God you've
been so outspoken did they go after your
family that's what I was going to ask
they did
um they first put me on the their
killing list yeah and I was informed by
social intelligence and then they put
all my families from Mom both sides and
denounced me as the popular program
lesson propaganda yes and then they all
disappear which means oh my God
wow now when you're in China you have
this unbelievable journey to get to
Mongolia and then from Mongolia to South
Korea you have to cross the Gobi desert
yeah
this is a 24-hour when I was listening
to the podcast you said it was a 24-hour
straight Journey it's negative 40
degrees what are you wearing how are you
staying warm like how do you prepare for
this are you taking water I'm trying to
understand piece of freeze water gonna
freeze yeah your entire thing is all
like ice if you breathe it becomes like
oh like icically yeah so uh I that's the
thing I was rescued by missionaries yes
and they said you have to believe in
miracles otherwise you're not going to
make this journey the chance of
surviving is a one percent
so but we don't have like gloves or
gears or like paddings you know just
some like thick jackets
and then no gloves no scarves no hat and
so afterwards we got everything Frozen
or a Facebook wire for us to hit our
skin yeah yeah the missionaries that you
said would make you like they would test
you on the Bible and if you didn't do
well they might not take you did they do
that just so you would believe in
miracles more strongly was that the idea
do you know why because it seemed to me
I was like you'll just rescue these
people who cares how well they know the
Bible right so that's the thing uh they
believe that North Korean people cannot
learn about Bible because the Kim's copy
the Bible and brainwashed Us in the same
Theology and like if people hear about
God and Jesus Christ we're gonna like
know the same thing they're telling us
so in North Korea if you read a Bible
you get executed wow
yeah it's like this the biggest crime
you can make in North Korea so these
Christians thought like they need to
save North Koreans and let them know the
gospel so they rescued us and the price
was us becoming Christians and that's
why we had to write down those songs and
memorize and testing and praying and
fasting and months of training then God
would have just saved them but that's
foreign
yeah really I became one after my son I
wasn't I was a atheist for a long time
yeah it makes sense and having my son
like work this is a miracle it's I had
to become yeah one okay okay so then you
eventually get to South Korea from South
Korea you come over here you study at
Colombia and now you've just gotten your
citizenship Bravo hey yeah
[Music]